[Music]
extinction is a Netflix original science
fiction movie starring Michael Pena the
film's plot hinges on a huge twist and
due to the level it subverts
expectations - it may leave some viewers
confused throughout this video I will be
discussing the ending of extinction as
well as the events that led up to it
there will be heavy spoilers and the
film is definitely worth seeing for the
twist alone so I highly recommend that
you come back to this video if you're
yet to watch it with that out the way
I'm definition and I ruin the movie so
you don't have to Peter is haunted by a
recurring dream that the planet is going
to be invaded by deadly aliens hell-bent
on destruction horrifyingly the visions
come to reality and the planet begins
being attacked by mysterious beings
after overpowering one Peter comes to
the realization that underneath the
alien like costume is a young and
frightened boy this ties into the
conclusion in which we discover that
Peters visions are not actually that of
the future but they are in fact the past
in which there was a war between
synthetics and humans we discover that
all of the protagonists that we have
been following are in fact highly
sophisticated artificial intelligence
this leads into the backstory in which
humans had invented artificially
intelligent robots called syntax which
appeared almost identical to them in
every way used initially for all range
of menial labor it doesn't take long for
concern to grow amongst the humans and
using the military they decide to
attempt to wipe them all out this
however fails and when the synthetics
fight back they beat humanity to the
point that surviving humans of the war
must flee the planet at this point most
synthetics voluntary wipe their memories
and begin blissful new lives as humans
on earth while a few robots retain their
memories and prepare for the inevitable
return of human
this is where the phone begins and when
the humans do eventually show up the
synthetics flee to safe houses to
prepare for the inevitable war and the
film's closed whilst the movie is rather
open-ended Ben young the director of the
film's stated that if we do go down the
path of a sequel I'd love to hear the
human perspective of what went on after
they reclaimed the planet how would they
hunt down the synthetics I'd love to see
the narrative continue and this has
definitely piqued my interest to the
point that I hope Netflix produces a
sequel one of the biggest questions that
you may have when leaving the film is
why do the humans look the way they do
again Ben Young recently stated that it
was very difficult coming up with the
costumes designed to show their age we
see a hint of what costumes may have
looked like when they were brand new
they've been conditioned and weathered
to hell we began by designing them
looking more traditional and then aged
them down this makes sense as resources
in space would have been so low humans
would have had to keep a hold of
anything that they had when they left
the planet with and will have been
forced to make the best out of what they
took when cleaned from Earth another
question you may have had is why did the
robots act so human in an interview with
inverse a Michael Pena stated that he
struggled with the role due to the fact
he had to act human to a certain point
but also robotic to the level that the
movie would make sense when watched a
second time because they had their
memories wiped it's clear they wanted to
hide from themselves that they were in
fact synthetic so would have been
programmed to a point where they could
even fool themselves due to their
portrayal of humanity do you think that
actors in the film achieved this and
what are your thoughts on extinction
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel I create content
like this weekly a little definitely
something on here that you love if
you're a fan of film make sure you check
out my breakdown of Mission Impossible
fallout at the end of this video
for my thoughts on that fantastic film
and thanks again for taking the time to
watch this video
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you